now let's take a little deeper look at
what is contained inside of the data
array now if you recall each layer is
actually a large two-dimensional grid of
tile data it's listed here in the JSON
file as a single integer array
effectively this is what we call raster
scan order where each row is listed in
the file after the previous row linearly
the value of each element in the data
array actually has significance in
itself first off if you see a zero value
that effectively means that no tile has
been placed in that XY position inside
of this layer any nonzero value
represents a tile index for a given
Atlas now this is where things start to
get a little bit tricky now if you
recall this little element here first
GID that exists for each Atlas that's
listed in our tile sets array now if a
zero value in the data array for a layer
means that there's no tile there that
means that the first element to
represent that a tile does exist must
start with one each Atlas that exists
inside of the tiled file will have an
increasing first GID
now tiled has its own heuristics on what
the first GID should be for each
subsequent Atlas that's loaded we won't
get into that
other than to say that you need to know
what this number is so what we see here
is that if we have a value of 167 in
this data array and the first GID of the
Atlas starts with 1 this effectively
means that 167 is the first Atlas tile
number 166 now this makes a little bit
more sense once you start getting four
or five different Atlas layers on there
right now it may seem a little bit
gobbledygook the larger issue that you
have to run into is what does 166
actually mean
now recall once again that the Atlas
that's being given to us is in raster
scan order as well so the value of 166
is actually the raster index into the
two-dimensional array with this set up
computing the coordinates for the Atlas
simply involves mapping the tile size to
the right offset inside the Atlas itself